sechs tage lang lief er im juli 2020
mehr als 2000 polizisten bei einer
kontrolle hatte er vier beamte
entwaffnet war mit ihren dienstpistolen
im dickicht des schwarzwaldes
verschwunden das war passiert vier
polizisten sind in zwei streifenwagen zu
einer holzhütte in oppenau angerückt sie
steht gleich am weiteren der besitzer
der gartenlaube hat die beamten
alarmiert er war länger nicht dort und
entdeckte nun einen schlafenden mann in
seiner hütte an der wand lehnen pfeil
und bogen als die polizisten die hütte
betreten sitzt am tisch er ist
überrascht aber kooperativ
er ist obdachlos hat die lange
ungenutzte hütte schon vor einer weile
besetzt nun händigt er den polizisten
eine weste mit patronengurt einen speer
pfeil und bogen aus ohne widerstand zu
leisten
er ist anfang dreißig einer der aus der
gesellschaft gefallen ist der sich unter
bäumen wohler fühlt als unter menschen
er hat eine lange geschichte des
scheiterns hinter sich die eltern
trennten sich als sie vier jahre alt ist
kinderheime pflegeeltern acht mal muss
er die schule wechseln bis er den
hauptschulabschluss schafft 2009 kaufte
er sich eine sport armbrust mit dieser
waffe schießt er seiner mitbewohnerin
nach einem streit in die brust dafür
geht er dreieinhalb jahre in den knast
waffen darf er nun nicht mehr tragen
wieder frei hält er sich mit
gelegenheitsjobs über wasser
aber auch das scheitert 2018 zeit er
seine miete nicht fliegt aus seiner
unterkunft im oktober 2009 10 geht aus
amt meldet sich ab unbekannt verzogen
zurück in die hütte zum 12 juli 2020
jetzt stehen auf einmal polizisten vor
ihm er ist auf bewährung draußen liebt
die freiheit brennt dem waldläufer wie
er sich selber genannt haben soll nun
aus angst die sicherung durch als einer
der beamten ihn vor der hütte
durchsuchen will zieht er eine
schreckschusswaffe erzwingt die
polizisten ihre waffen auf den boden zu
legen
steckt sie ein und flüchtet warum ist
die situation eskaliert
der schwarzwald rambo sagt weil der
beamte ihn ohne respekt behandelt haben
soll herablassend und provozierend nach
tagen auf der flucht ist eve er
ausgezehrt hungrig dehydriert und müde
er zeigt sich einem postboten will nur
noch das alles aufhört
wenig später wird der wald rambow in
einem gebüsch vom sek gestellt die
versagt er hoffte dass er erschossen
wird ins gefängnis will er unter keinen
umständen als die beamten mit einem
taser auf ihn schießen greift er zu
einem ball schlägt um sich dabei trifft
er einen polizisten am fuß dann wird er
überwältigt wir sind bild und wir
liefern dir deine news auf youtube zum
nächsten video kommst du hier
und vergesst bitte nicht unseren kanal
zu abonnieren